and I make a joky so why don't you shove
a Ryobi drill up here and I tweet right
back why Ryobi yeah why not Makita
go with the Aquino but the guy wrote a
letter plumbers yes but the guy broke
back he's as sorry as had a tough day I
probably shouldn't have said that so at
least I had an inner pleasure whether
what did that come out of out of nowhere
this meanness that was a clip from Adam
Carolla and dennis prager 'he's upcoming
new movie it's called no safe spaces
comedy used to be the realm of liberals
in America but that has changed recently
turn on any late-night show humor is
gone it's dead it's been replaced by
suffocating propaganda and mindless
repetitive political correctness is that
permanent can it be fixed can the
country regain its sense of humor
its sense of art its sense of dignity
really in perspective we had that
conversation in part two of our
interview with Corolla and Prager here's
part of what they said what if everyone
simultaneously stopped apologizing
stopped backpedaling stop walking back
tweets when they were tweeting a quoting
Winston Churchill and then they had to
apologize after quoting Winston
Churchill or whomever or whatever what
if it all stopped on Monday there'd be
no more business on Tuesday for the
people or accession to town if we did it
and we provided a uniform front if we
all just sort of said no I'm not gonna
apologize it was a joke or you took it
the wrong way or I meant it live with it
this would end immediately let's do that
can you think since you guys have just
spent the last more than a year working
on this film about this topic can you
think of anyone who's done that
who was other than you all who's just
drawing the line in normal life and I'm
sorry I'm not gonna apologize for Donald
Trump
good point and that's what drives them
crazy he just marches on does his thing
overwhelmingly it has been good for the
United States and the world he has said
some ridiculous things even some bad
things fully acknowledged nevertheless
he does not apologize to the left
he he is the ultimate nemesis of the
left because he doesn't care what they
say and I have said often I'm a
religious guy and I have said there was
more fear of the left in America than
fear of God there's more fear of the New
York Times editorial page than fear of
God and either even if you're an atheist
you you can acknowledge the truth of
that and that when you bust that fear
it's over there they they wish that the
fear will work that that's why they they
gather around your table and scream with
you because the previous tactic didn't
work so they keep upping it but at a
given point it won't work and that's the
hope that the American people understand
there's a vicious cycle taking place on
the part not of liberals but of leftists
in our film Alan Dershowitz says as a
liberal as a Democrat as an American as
a Jew by far more fear the left than the
right yeah I think people do so how long
does this last there's well I think
there's also quick addendum here like a
simple thing we could do I think we're
all guilty of doing it
I listen i watch your show I listen to
your show religiously even though man it
is and and you guys do it and I don't
think it's unconscious and we all do it
where you go look here are my thoughts
on immigration and then you stop and you
go Hispanics are great people I work
with many Hispanic people I have no ill
will my heart toward his favor and then
you go ahead and talk about securing the
border and then you do this thing where
you go or it's a feminine issue I'm
married I have daughters I love them
dearly I don't abuse my wife
ritualistically now why do we have to
preface everything it's very funny look
I'm not an arsonist I'm not a pedophile
here are my views
I'm not a racist this nose of course
you're not a racist you're not a racist
I'm not a racist in theory I make a few
off-color jokes my point is we shouldn't
have to preface every talking point with
I'm not misogynistic I'm not sick I'm
not homophobic I'm not raising we're not
this is insane that they've talked us
into having to preface every talking
point with I have nothing against
homosexuals many my best friends are gay
dennis is a godfather to a homosexual
couple now that being said let me give
you my thoughts on gay marriage this
notion that they've talked good with
family people who've never brought any
harm to any group regardless of sexual
proclivities or gender age or race we've
ever done anything why do we have to
start every every bundle to every
argument with look I'm not I'm not
homophobic and I'm not a racist
and I'm not of it and then you explain
you have a wife and she honey are you
here by the way this is good stuff
anyway if you're missing a lot of good
stuff the boy says let's stop doing that
no variety I know time we never doing
that it was right into your talking
point you're not homophobic and you're
not racist and you're not xenophobe and
not actually you're not why why do we
have to prove that to nut job who's
arguing with you and who's got you on
your heels because you have to make sure
that they know you're not a racist at
every turn you just changed my show from
here and I will not gentlemen thank you
I can't wait for the movie it's great to
see you thanks